cuando analizamos comunidades de
organismos una pregunta muy interesante
es qué tan diversas son esas comunidades
aquí he puesto dos ejemplos de
comunidades cada una consiste en varias
especies de círculos supongamos que cada
color representa una especie entonces
pausa en el vídeo y reflexione cuál de
estas comunidades piensan que será la
más diversa bueno si analizamos a la
comunidad número uno podemos ver que hay
círculos de dos colores diferentes o lo
podemos ver como dos especies distintas
mientras que la comunidad número dos
tiene cuatro especies diferentes así que
podríamos decir que la comunidad número
2 es más diversa pero como podríamos
cuantificar esto bueno para ayudarnos
con eso los biólogos han desarrollado
una herramienta que se conoce como el
índice de diversidad de simpson que
consiste en un número entre 0 y 1 donde
1 corresponde a una comunidad muy
diversa y 0 significa que no hay
diversidad lo escribiré el índice
este es el índice de diversidad y luego
n mayúscula será la población total en
esa comunidad es decir el número total
de todos los individuos sin importar la
especie entonces número de todos los
individuos los individuos y después en
el subíndice y será el número de
individuos de cada especie que vamos a
llamar especie y entonces número de
individuos de la especie
y lo que estoy diciendo es que por
ejemplo si aquí hay dos especies esta
sería la primera especie y esta sería la
segunda entonces sería 1 y 2 pero como
aquí tenemos 4 sería el número de
individuos de la primera segunda tercera
o de la cuarta especie
pero como pondríamos todos esos números
para obtener el índice de diversidad
bueno para eso podemos usar esta fórmula
vamos a probarla varias veces para
entender cómo funciona mire el índice de
diversidad de simpson es igual a 1 - la
sumatoria del producto de n subíndice y
por en el subíndice y menos 1 y todo eso
entre n mayúscula por n mayúscula menos
1 bien y para saber cómo funciona qué
les parece si calculamos el índice de
diversidad de simpson de una de estas
comunidades vamos a ver para la
comunidad número 1 podemos escribir que
el índice de diversidad de simpson es
igual a 1 menos
primero escribiré el denominador cuál es
el número total de la población vamos a
ver 1 2 300 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12
entonces
n mayúscula es 12 tenemos 12 x 12 menos
uno que es 11 entonces 12 x 11 y arriba
primero pensemos en la población de los
círculos azules que la podemos ver como
nuestra primera especie así que tenemos
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 entonces será 7 por 7
menos uno nos queda 7 por 6 y a eso le
vamos a sumar la población de la segunda
especie tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 entonces
tenemos 5 por 5 menos uno que es 4 ok y
esto cuánto nos da bueno esto es igual a
1 - arriba tenemos 42 más 20 así que son
y 2 entre 12 por 11 que son 132 y esto
es igual la vamos a usar la calculadora
tenemos 62 entre 132 que es igual a eso
después le pongo el signo negativo y
sumamos 1 más 1 y eso es igual a 0.53
entonces todo esto es aproximadamente
igual a 0.53 ahora los invito a que
pausa en el vídeo y traten de calcular
el índice de diversidad de simpson para
la comunidad número 2
vean si pueden resolverlo por su cuenta
antes de que lo hagamos juntos
vamos a resolverlo juntos en este caso
la comunidad número 2 déjenme separar
esto con una línea para no confundirnos
bueno en este caso nuestro índice de
diversidad de simpson será igual a 1 - y
en el denominador ahora tenemos vamos a
ver 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13
entonces tenemos 13 individuos en total
y colocamos 13
13 1 que sería por 12 y después en el
numerador ahora tenemos vamos a ver
digamos que los círculos azules son
nuestra primera especie y tenemos 4 en
total 1 2 3 4 así que escribimos 4 x 4 -
ahora veamos qué pasa con los círculos
de color naranja
bueno observen que tenemos tres así que
escribimos más tres por tres menos uno y
después podemos analizar a la especie de
color morado que como tenemos dos nos
queda más 2 x
2 1 finalmente pensemos en la especie de
color verde tenemos 1 2 3 4
entonces nos queda más 4 x 4 -1 ok y
todo esto es igual a 1 - vamos a ver
aquí tenemos 12 + 6 que es igual a 18
más 220 más 12 nos da 32 entonces nos
queda uno menos 32 entre cuando es 13
por 12 bueno eso es igual a 156 entonces
entre 156 ahora si usemos la calculadora
tenemos que 32 entre 156 es igual a esto
y vamos a restar lo a 1 nos queda que
todo esto es aproximadamente igual a
0.79 entonces esto es aproximadamente
igual
0.79 así que al final hemos obtenido
números que nos confirman lo que ya
sabíamos antes intuitivamente miren me
refiero a que por el índice de
diversidad de simpson podemos ver que
esta comunidad tiene más diversidad que
esta y si quieren saber cómo sería una
comunidad en donde no existe ninguna
diversidad imagínense una comunidad en
donde solamente existe una sola especie
de hecho los invito a que se la imaginen
y piensen en cuál sería el índice de
diversidad de simpson para supongamos
que tenemos a la comunidad número 3
comunidad número 3
piensen en cuál sería el índice de
diversidad de esta comunidad si
solamente tuviéramos 3 individuos y
todos fueran de la misma especie e
igualmente los invito a que reflexionen
sobre la comunidad número 4 comunidad
número 4 porque en esta comunidad tal
vez solo hay un individuo de cada
especie
piensen en cuál sería el índice de
diversidad de simpson para esta
comunidad